how would you describe what the circle
is to say your grandmother
it's the chaos of the web made elegant
speed round Paul or John early Paul late
John Mario or Sonic really sonic late
Mario needs of the society or needs of
the individual should be the same you're
most scared of unfulfilled potential I
[Music]
am a believer in the perfectibility of
human beings
we are our best selves the possibilities
are endless
at the circle there isn't a problem that
we cannot solve we can cure any disease
and we can and hunger without secrets
without the hoarding of knowledge and
information
we can finally realize our potential
circulars if you like to share
[Music]
we will see it all let's
if it happens we'll know
imagine the human rights implications
there needs to be accountability
what is this the circle has a power to
changed everything
so we are Liza get us in trouble things
we hide we care about everybody you care
about
because knowing is
yes better
[Music]
you
[Music]
you